along with inflation Americans are
suffering from so-called tip flation
that is due in part to the growth of
digital payments and often automatically
ask for tips you know what we're talking
about some people think it is out of
control I'm hearing some in
Carter Evans shows us how one business
is trying to solve the
activity guilt
when you pay for your ice cream in Molly
Moons in Seattle then would you like to
receive my friend leaving a tip is not
allowed I have to say I'm highly annoyed
at to thing now owner Molly moon neitzel
says her employees didn't like it either
it's really awkward especially in the
counter service interaction to watch
someone make a decision it never feels
good credit card processor Square says
almost 75 percent of remote transactions
now ask for gratuity and it may be
leading to a tipping backlash from the
drive-through homegirl
or to the donut shop I'm not throwing in
that added tip on just a coffee a new
Bankrate survey suggests two-thirds of
Americans now have a negative view about
tipping and the number of people who
always leave a tip is declining down 10
percent even at sit-down restaurants in
just the last two years but tipping can
be hard to eliminate when restaurants
replace tipping with higher menu prices
their online ratings go down Cornell
University Professor Michael Lynn says
technology makes it easier for
non-traditional businesses to ask for a
little extra like electricians or
plumbers that might be embarrassed to
ask for a tip in person but when they
send you an electronic bill they can
include a tip request back when Molly
Moon's accepted tips she says the
biggest winners were credit card
processors because they make more on the
credit card processing fees and she says
the data from the very checkout system
that asked for tips showed they led to
pay inequities
black employees at Molly Moons were
making a lot less than white employees
absolutely and so it became clear to us
how unfair our total compensation system
was now she pays a minimum of 21 an hour
plus full health care 401K match and
child care assistance 520 P.M to pay for
it all she did raise prices but she says
it evens out our customers didn't pay
any more we just shifted how the money
came in for CBS mornings I'm Carter
Evans in Seattle
all right I like that model it's like
the European model include the tip price
essentially baked into the price for the
food or the products and that way
there's no anxiety yeah you would hope
that the employees are taken care of
yeah by the employer yeah I imagine the
only pushback is if you don't have cash
to pay the higher price at least with a
tip you can opt out so if you're a lower
income worker yourself maybe you don't
want to pay that extra amount but I do
like higher wages overall yeah and I'll
say those self-serve kiosks where
they're asking for a tip come on that's
just disrespectful Nate they know you
they see you on TV they will post about
you that's about it that's about it